500 años después la lucha del pueblo
mapuche para la restitución de sus
tierras ancestrales no cesa aquí lloran
a su ultimo comunero muerto un joven de
24 años fallecido en un confuso
incidente con las fuerzas armadas en
circunstancias que aún se investigan
venimos a rendir homenaje con todo un
sentido de un compromiso de unidad del
pueblo nación mapuche
y siempre estamos diciendo que en esta
lucha
tenemos que saber un solo cuerpo un solo
un zoológico la muerte del joven generó
protestas y se produjo días antes del
aniversario del polémico asesinato de
otro comunero mapuche camilo catrillanca
a manos de la policía chilena los
representantes de los pueblos
originarios a cargo de escribir una
nueva constitución y algunos compañeros
emprendieron camino al palacio de la
moneda para entregar una carta al
presidente en la calidad de
convencionales de pueblos originarios
mapuche y también del pueblo chileno
venimos a emplazarlo para que cese la
militarización y deje sin efecto este
decreto y no insista en el en estas
elecciones son varias las candidaturas
especialmente de mujeres que quieren
llevar la voz de los mapuches al
parlamento isabel cayón es una de ellas
entre sus demandas terminar con la
militarización del territorio mapuche o
one map el wallmapu se encuentra en
poder de las fuerzas militares que están
haciendo ataques a personas inocentes
personas que no están haciendo nada han
muerto
lo que se está defendiendo con el brazo
armado del gobierno de piñera son los
intereses de los grandes capitales
económicos que tienen puestos son
inversiones en las forestales su
candidatura representan la mirada de la
mujer indígena excluidas de los espacios
de poder en latinoamérica durante siglos
isabel cayul espera que ahora en este
nuevo chile que se construye se escuche
al fin su voz y la de su comunidad